[Music]
in enough is enough news is too much
submitted by love from Brazil oh yeah
the Brazilians got the booty I was
thinking about fried bananas plantains a
man wants to sue his wife in divorce
court for putting up with her disruptive
mother mother mother slowly you will
forget the English language I want a
stepmom huh I want to live with the mom
was it a lot
yeah mother-in-law not stepmom I could
live with disrupt yeah I'm down yeah cuz
I just see Jill's mom helping out cuz my
mother-in-law is good but imagine never
mind my mom is good yeah mom is dope my
mom is she wouldn't come over to the
house had her own key while worse we're
trying to sleep in on the weekend she
comes in opens the [ __ ] door robber
hang out why does she have the key to
your house oh nothing you want but when
we owned it but also every place I've
ever lived that she requested a key to
Wow
for this one you're like hell no yeah
sure [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] damn I was a
crazy [ __ ] I would definitely give my
mom a key to my house I my mom has a kid
just about my mom because I just know
like if I fight if she has a key the
house will be clean yeah and I'll have a
bunch of food there yeah that's what I
want I want to give your mom a key to my
house can we all just give your mother
you gave a key to my mom's house you'll
come home the house is remodeled we
[ __ ] came on one time and were like
wait where's her bathtub and then the
bathroom was gone cuz she wanted to
convert it into like one of those tile
showers and I'm like actually like the
bathtub I use the bathroom every now and
then
and now I can't even take a bad I can
only do shower is just straight awaited
the jet construction workers come
through pull the [ __ ] about the driveway
and then juice
that's [ __ ] hilarious dude hug my
house isn't even I thought we live in a
two-bedroom why is it only one bedroom
why why they're strangers in the other
room
oh I've rented it out oh my sighs okay
so this story mothballs mothballs both
moss
all right so this story takes place in
Ireland and there's this man who is
doing his or not sowing he told his wife
that he would build her for the cost of
accommodating her exceptionally
difficult and disruptive mother who has
been staying in their home and
apparently this went all the way to
court what a brave man brave man to do
that [ __ ] but it's at the divorce though
it's unfortunate but I can see why it
happens let's say we pick I don't think
that what did you sue me for my mom cuz
I pay you a gladly pay you know I think
what happened was he was at wit's end
he's like [ __ ] you know what we're
getting a [ __ ] divorce and now it's
like tired of it he's like yo like I
don't want to be with you I told you
about your [ __ ] mom I'm gonna split up
the marriage we spent this much unlike
me housing your [ __ ] mom [ __ ] that
pay me back I like how Gio builds a
backstory what if this guy is sucks yeah
yeah [ __ ] slob I think because I've
experienced a difficult mother I can
sigh project your own backstory on today
I like mom's no matter what though all
moms yeah even bars bonds awesome no
even though she calls me back you can't
say that until you live with someone do
you know what I mean like oh my you to
play ticket you guys go around the world
together alright I have so many awesome
story though mm-hmm yeah so this man is
just saying like uh you know he's just
had enough of his 78 year old
mother-in-law 78 yeah
ah yeah he's just like [ __ ] done cuz
he was saying that there was this one
morning the Saturday morning that him
and his wife were just having you know
night well I don't know what what is
lyin me for what do you mean I put it in
a sentence it says that he was having a
lion with his wife like oh yeah story so
they were just sleeping one Saturday
morning and the mother-in-law came into
the bedroom in her underwear I don't
know what'll happen that's like all they
mentioned she had dementia it could be
that's traumatizing for other things but
it was probably like a gown right it's
not like a bikini I mean there they said
underwear I don't know and then another
thing that she did at the gym the old
ladies love their liver they hang out in
the bathroom or gym floor no oh yes babe
on the gym floor in the US 24 hours no
cuz in the bathroom it's normal you're
supposed to let up came here well I mean
if they're Asian but like usually like
that doesn't really want I got Bally's
24 Aussies swinging dicks all the time
but you like it that's the difference
you're trying to grab looking for it
he's trying to grab mine he's like on
Yelp which one has the most six in the
bathroom that's what you have to ask him
at the front desk as I who has the
biggest long hair excuse me does the
bathroom sorry you're gonna have to go
to LA Fitness thanks but I'll take any
size I'm not picking this point yeah I
just want a lot of dicks yeah makes me
feel secure the mother-in-law also
rearranged his socks underwear and
shirts in his wardrobe that's nice I
like that I mean yeah that's kind of
nice but she also came into the bathroom
that's in the master bedroom while he
was drying himself after a shower like
she just walked into the but his mom
right
mother-in-law I mean she ain't gonna
suck his dick that's not the point there
are boundaries and that's his home but
he's like like it should be the other
way around right like no I'm sure it's
above so I think the the outline the
outline thing here is or the common
thing here is that she doesn't respect
this house she doesn't respect that it's
his home there's no respect but what was
her purpose because if I was in the
shower let's say Bart's mom comes in and
says I'm going to quit now I'll be like
oh hey you're clean she probably didn't
yeah she probably just goes in there
when you didn't even ask for her to
clean [ __ ] now she [ __ ] everything up
and and she does it the way she wants it
to be done maybe she has a crush on him
you know what it is you know what it is
what this guy is cuz he hasn't been
around his parents you have forgotten
what it's like to have an intrusive
parent
cuz I love my mom too but she'll come in
as your like that's not the right place
I'm like listen here [ __ ] yeah touch my
[ __ ] of course not in my know you know
what you know what idea that's how guys
talk though I don't really see I don't
care how the bathroom they're just salty
he's probably so nice yes momma yeah
momma
so now imagine yes that is exactly what
it does imagine you're like on a roll
and you're in this creative rolling
you're like reading a bunch of [ __ ] but
then your mom comes in and she wants to
talk about problems and now she wants
you to like stop it oh yeah I know her
and I close the door so remember that
feeling but now with every aspect of
your [ __ ] life and you can't get away
from it but then I to me it's a
give-and-take if she's doing my laundry
if she's cleaning my [ __ ] no soap really
this dude is like he cooks for her and
like makes her so he does and then
apparently he spent like 900 euros on
shrubs and plants for his home and then
the mother-in-law just pulled up the
plants and shrubs I didn't appeal to her
taste oh that's true low in the past me
see I never had a mom like got too far
I'm on inside I guess I don't I don't
know how to empathize cuz I didn't have
a mom like that yeah we we we get
[ __ ] on yeah another thing that she
would do is like Hubie watching
television just having a nice time like
you poured a glass of wine just enjoying
the TV and this lady comes in bursting
through the door like yelling at him
about the TV being on and telling him
that he thought yeah he's like I'm sorry
you're a guest in my home you cannot
raise your voice that mean tell me what
to watch you don't talk to them like
that you got a [ __ ] control the
[ __ ] wild animal damn what kind of
son are you that's true just [ __ ]
yelled at me I would have [ __ ]
grabbed some [ __ ] taco hot sauce
packets and threw it out her face and
said shut the [ __ ] no again nope nope
you will I guess mama that's true my mom
and I get it I'm scared of my mom my mom
is a [ __ ] crazy ass 5-foot woman man
don't [ __ ] with I love the fantasies
though me and my mom we do argue though
okay why don't say but we got into
yelling matches though damn you are
Davey thank you I haven't got mad at my
mom in a long time I kind of miss
fighting with her oh never move in dude
no I just go like I just kind of go okay
bye and I hang up while she's talking
fiery as [ __ ] you know what I mean she
hasn't calmed down at all yeah and
that's why we still argue like for
example like there was like some family
drama that was going on but it was
something my dad didn't need to know
because my dad gets angry really quick
so hey don't tell Dad she goes God hangs
up the phone I get a call from my dad he
starts screaming at me I'm like yeah
what the [ __ ] hang up the phone I call
my mom she goes oh oh [ __ ] I do remember
I got my I'm mad at my mom in Japan
I do remember but it's it's for its for
weird reasons
so like it's cuz she's overly nice so
like me and Jess we're looking for a
bathroom right and then there was a bus
that was gonna come on my alright [ __ ]
we ain't got no time we got to go that
McDonald's so we run up and she's like
like she's down to block and she's like
screaming at the bus stop and I'm like
oh [ __ ] what happened and then she's
like [ __ ] running and then like we're
running and I'm just sprinting to the
middle of the block and I'm like what
happened and she goes it might not be
open
I just ran into like I can use the
restroom they let me use it or like
shirts right there [ __ ] [ __ ] and I
walked out of my mom I'm in the rush
like why did you stop me what because
it's not a boy she's a worrier
I'm like Fogg dude I thought someone was
dying in [ __ ] way down the block you
might have to buy something do that we
won't we go away but he went like this
[ __ ] Mary Lopez - it really irritates
the [ __ ] out of me there she goes
oh my god something happened I gotta
tell you later something I don't like
you know I [ __ ] yeah emergency or not
yeah I was like you can't do that I mean
cuz it [ __ ] me up and so that will see
other what happened she goes my project
I pushed oh my god I'm like okay sorry I
freaked you out but no it's really not
that big with you yeah no.11 I'll see
you tomorrow
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] it's hilarious but my dad
was like I was like that
[Music]